if you decided one day to rank the worst
business decisions in all of recorded
human history you'd have a lot of
options to choose from maybe you'd go
with Blockbusters refusal to buy Netflix
for the bargain price of $50 million or
you might point to all the Publishers
that passed on the first Harry Potter
book more recently of course there's Bud
Light there's also Target selling a
satanic merchandise that sexualizes
children whatever comes to mind when you
think of massive business failures as of
today you should know that there's yet
another Contender for the throne of
worst business decision in history or at
least for maybe one of the runner-up
positions and it's perhaps the most
foreseeable financial disaster of all
time a couple years ago the lingerie
store Victoria Secret opted to uh
replace its world famous angels that are
supermodels with obese women and
profoundly unhappy lesbian feminists
they literally hired Megan rapino the
purple-haired soccer player just to give
you an idea of how sexless and
androgynous the marketing became not
anybody with two working eyes or a basic
understanding of human sexuality it was
obvious from the beginning how this
strategy would turn out it would be a
complete embarrassment to everybody
associated with it it would make
millions of people dramatically less
likely to buy products from Victoria
Secret because not very many people want
to look like Megan rapino or look at her
no offense to her it's just the reality
but our moral superiors in the news
industry didn't see it that way two
years ago they were convinced that
Victoria's Secret with its bold decision
to reject Beauty and replace replace it
with whatever they replace it with was
about to bring about a SE change in
human sexuality they were they were
going to fundamentally alter the entire
concept of attractiveness in one Fell
Swoop so look at this footage of a local
news station in Minnesota from back in
2021 covering this new initiative from
Victoria Secret listen to to every
moment of this because honestly it it
belongs in a time capsule
watch our Sunrise live with a story
gaining steam online Victoria Secrets
changing their image trying to answer
the agal question of what women really
want and apparently it's not wings or
stilettos yeah the company announcing
their new initiative the Victoria Secret
Collective which includes women famous
for their various achievements and not
their proportions like soccer star and
gender equality Advocate Megan rapo and
actress Priyanka choer Jones now the
brand is looking to be more inclusive
Bringing Sexy Back by representing real
women that come in all shapes and sizes
from all different backgrounds the
company is hoping these diverse leading
icons and change change makers are going
to do just that now as of late the
company's been viewed as outdated and
has been accused of fostering a sexist
brand image but now the company's
executive team is mostly all women
Martin Waters Who's chief executive of
the brand said we needed to stop being
about what men want and it be about what
women want and folks of course sounding
off uh this person here writing ining
that was never made by women for women
it was what men wanted women to be and
another writes the sexy underwear
garbage was was always about satisfying
the male fantasy it had nothing to do
with women at all so they think it's an
interesting shift and last but not least
this one here from Sharon say no problem
with angels just the lack of comfort
size diversity and fit so you guys yeah
I feel like after going through a lot of
the comments a lot of people are saying
it's about time they changed their image
yeah I mean the world has evolved and
women know we've known this for a long
time we' come in all shapes sizes colors
so I think this is a good move
so so Victoria Secret is uh Bringing
Sexy Back says one of the news readers
quoting the great Justin Timberlake and
then comes the anchor woman to tell us
uh what to make of all this the world
has evolved she says and now in this
enlightened era we've made an
astonishing Discovery and that Discovery
says the anchor woman is that women come
in all shapes sizes and colors imagine
that I mean before the year 2021 nobody
knew that women were individuals instead
of complete carbon copies of one another
we didn't we didn't know about that in
fact we just figured out a couple of
years ago um after all this time and
therefore the anchorwoman concludes it's
a a good move by Victoria Seeker to
feature a bunch of women who are
morbidly obese in their advertising now
for a moment if you can forget about the
stupidity and the ignorance of what all
these people are saying pretend that
local news stations aren't completely
brainless collections of NPCs who just
read whatever script they are given
Focus instead on on the sheer hubris of
it I mean what you have here is a mediet
proudly proclaiming without any
hesitation that all of human history got
it wrong what this anchor was saying and
what Victoria Secret was saying is that
the innate sexual impulses of millions
of Americans can be basically
reprogrammed overnight their conception
of Aesthetics and beauty is you know not
inherit that be could be easily changed
and all people have to do she's saying
is accept their internalized misogyny
and promise to be good allies to
Corporate America and unattractive women
everywhere and then soon enough they'll
come to believe that fat lesbian women
are attractive now fast forward just two
years into the future and it goes
without saying that this master plan to
re-engineer all of human sexuality has
failed from an empirical perspective in
2020 the year before this campaign began
Victoria Secret posted $7.5 billion in
Revenue this year the company is
projected to hit just 6.2 billion in
Revenue their stock price is down
something like 50% that's 5 in the past
year as a result predictably this week
CN reported that Victoria Secret is in
panic mode and they're reversing course
quote the Victoria Secret Rebrand is
over that was CNN's headline CNN then
quoted the company's chief executive is
saying quote despite everyone's best
Endeavors it's not been enough to carry
the day so this new master plan has
collapsed it's not viable they're losing
a huge amount of money and uh and so
they're giving up none of that's
surprising I mean any normal human being
could have predicted this outcome a long
time ago what's interesting about this
whole situation is that Victoria Secret
chief executive and their friend at CNN
uh desperately don't want to talk about
the key question underlying all of this
and and that key question is why did
this initiative fail exactly you can
understand at some level why Victoria's
Secret wants to punt on that question
they don't want to accuse their
customers of being sexist pigs who
objectify women but they also don't want
to go into any G great detail about why
they thought this Rebrand was a good
idea in the first place so they're just
papering over the whole thing but it's
not that simple and everybody involved
in this catastrophe knows that the truth
is that
you know Victoria Secret did not go
Rogue they didn't make some uniquely
poor business decision it was a poor
business decision but not unique instead
they were doing what the rest of the
fashion industry and the media are doing
they were following the footsteps of
Target and Bud Light or Calvin kin
started using morbidly obese underwear
models a few years ago and many other
fashion companies you know look at
runways now and uh it's like you know
you see characters that you would have
seen in sideway you know in Sideshow
freak shows in the past on runways you
may remember this billboard from Calvin
Klein this is a you know morbidly obese
woman on the
billboard it's all social engineering
they wanted to redefine what
heterosexual males find attractive they
thought they had that power because well
they know best and they truly believe
their customers are stupid and
impressionable and they thought they
could they could transform them into
pronoun toing lefties and do it pretty
easily a lot of major media corporations
still subscribe to this God complex by
the way take Maxim magazine for example
this is a publication that uh used to be
dedicated to printing pictures of uh
scantily clad women so it was never
really a high quality magazine to begin
with but what are they up to lately as
the daily wire reports Maxim magazine
named a biological male and former
Australian Rules Football player
Danielle ladley to its hottest 100 women
list in Australia for 2023 with the
Trans identifying man landing in the
number 92 spot L who played and coached
in the Australian football league joined
actress Margo Robbie on The Hot List who
was named the hottest woman for the
fourth time now for the record and you
know just just for your own edification
if you're wondering here is Daniel
ly you know I was in I was in the 1.8
um% of transgender people who hit it
from the world be vulnerable find some
people who you can trust
um who you can talk to and they'll
support you and
invariably everything will be okay I
told my truth which was you know to to
help to help D out and and tell her
story the best way that
I there's the sun there having to
pretend to be proud uh so and that was
ranked by Maxim to be uh one of the top
100 hottest women and what was it 92
right so can you imagine if you were the
woman who landed at 93 or four 5 6 7 8 9
like can you imagine making it on the
list below
him now there's no point in being cruel
here let's just State this as
objectively as we possibly can a men's
magazine that used to be dedicated to
scantily clad women is now trying to
convince us that a dude who looks like a
you know a Middle School gym teacher is
not only a chick but a hot chick who we
should find attractive they're trying to
Gaslight heterosexual males into being
something other than heterosexual males
just like Victoria Secret was trying to
do it's laughable and nobody takes it
seriously it will fail like the Victoria
Secret campaign failed but the financial
implications of all this are relevant in
the big scheme of things what's really
interesting about these debacles is what
they tell us about the dominant ideology
among American leftists that for one
thing they really think they're Gods
they believe that Millennia of human
development are not important leftists
truly believe that they have the power
to alter something as fundamental as
human
sexuality they think they think they can
convince women that deep down they want
to be fat and unappealing as the chief
executive Victoria secer put it quote we
need we needed to stop being about what
men want and want to be one about what
women want but the truth is women don't
want to be gross or obese or unhealthy
they have agency regardless of how
aggressively the supposed feminists in
Corporate America want to deny it and
from the past two years and from all of
human history before that it's clear
that women do value the ideal of beauty
they aspire to it just like men do and
the more people of either gender are
told to rebel against those Basic
Instincts the more they inevitably rebel
against the charlatans who are lying to
them about it you ever get the feeling
that someone's watching you like even
when there's no one else in the room
well now I know you're probably thinking
it's Halloween season you're just being
paranoid but when it comes to your
online activity there is someone
watching everything you do and that
someone is your internet service
provider every website you visited uh
how much time you've spent on each they
know all of it and that's why I use
expressvpn expressvpn is an app that we
all need to be using see in the US
internet service providers are legally
allowed to sell all of their users
browsing activity to advertisers and
it's not just them your network admin
whether that's at your school or
workplace they can see everything you
click on as well but with expressvpn
100% of your traffic is rerouted through
their encrypted servers so no one can
see anything my favorite part is how
expressvpn is uh very simple to use you
just you open up the app you tap one
button and that's it it's that easy and
expressvpn it works on all your devices
whether you browse the internet on your
phone tablet or computer you can use up
to five devices at the same time time
under one expressvpn subscription so
stop letting people invade your privacy
visit expressvpn.com Walsh use my link
to get three extra months free that's
exps vpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com
Walsh for Victoria's Secret uh this has
been a very costly but important lesson
for everyone else on the far left this
would be what Barack Obama calls a
teachable moment they could choose to
stop denying the innate differences
among the SE Sexes they could decide to
stop pretending that they can override
thousands of years of human
evolution they could choose instead to
embrace humility and common sense if
only for their own
self-interest or these companies can
continue on their quest to convince
Americans that somehow they don't
actually find beauty
attractive Victoria Secret and Maxim and
Calvin Klein and every other company
that believes it can change human nature
through woke scolding and sanctimonious
TV news hits they can continue to thrust
obesity and other forms of ugliness in
our faces and insist that we pretend
they're
attractive if they go down that path
they'll they'll continue to bleed money
matter how much they're promoted on
MSNBC in the view they'll lose billions
more
dollars until they come to terms with
reality and they renounce their attempts
to re-engineer human psychology and
sexuality they will suffer they'll
Hemorrhage employees and money they'll
wage a losing battle against human
nature
itself and they will remain
indefinitely
canceled if you'd like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt wall Show Twitter page
hope to see you there Godspeed